[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
where we talk about whatever we want and
we got Eric back while you're not
excited I'm excited can I can we warm up
it's gonna be a long day so we got a I'm
trying to save you some of my energy
yeah I want to hear about your
girlfriend with a simple relationship
because that's one kind of cheap that's
very difficult the first couple seconds
achieve bliss for the both of us well
you know what it is
one thing I'll say for my girl she gets
over things fast so even if we're
fighting like I know 50 minutes later
she's cool with it
so before I would keep it going like my
it was my anger that kept things gone so
what I realized is I gotta go if she's
already ready to let it go I gotta let
it go yeah yeah yeah then we're just
like oh this is great
so the key is to date dumb girls no
that's not I wouldn't say that she just
lets go of things quicker yeah she does
things go that's a superpower though it
is you control you're like I'm done with
that dumb no that's not dumb that was a
joke yeah that can be viewed as dumb
like wow they have so few brain cells
that they can't even hold on to an
argument no it's not even about that she
makes her point she knows why she's
upset I think that the dope but she gets
about she doesn't need to be upset
anymore she lets go the emotions she has
the intellectual part but the emotion
part but in 15 minutes like how can I
learn his power I know that's what I
thought she's taught it to me because I
was the one holding onto it like that I
was like wait a minute she's already
over this so let me get over it you know
and then another thing she likes to do
too is like in the middle of a fight
show us to hug mmm
you know how fuses you know how hard it
is to hug somebody that you're angry at
but let me tell you something it's a
moment you do it because you
let it go because I fire up that someone
wants to hug me in the middle of five my
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] I'm gonna squeeze a
share of it yeah we'll say you have
issues oh yeah a lot but don't actually
make contact then I'm kind of like I'm
saying soon as you make contact with him
so it's like it's important but I was in
therapy my therapist told me that like
in an argument you're supposed to say
like it for every one thing bad thing
you say you have to do five good things
but these are all these are all coping
mechanisms these are all techniques you
have to like strengthen your
relationship but the you know the male
ego yeah what if she's being a real
[ __ ] though it's a person ego what if
she's being a real [ __ ] very legitimate
question a real one not a fake one yeah
well I mean but she here's a thing that
energy once you understand you have to
understand the reasons mens are [ __ ]
live by you divas two men are divas we
have to understand you have to
understand why she acting like a [ __ ]
right yes Steve is on a period oh yeah
but listen that's usually the source
let's say that let's say that that is
the thing well then why we don't see you
stupid fine okay good good
I like that I like that yeah that's what
I'm saying so we're listening that's why
we got in trouble no we're not listening
is with me I also must defend my honor
okay but but by the way we're not
listening because you haven't said
what's really wrong I saw you guys like
just say things like you should know you
know because they said no you don't say
you don't say and then you come back
later with like you go so tell me what's
wrong you know like I always say pretend
I don't know what the [ __ ] is wrong over
Ted just pretend let's pretend I know
that's a good way to start yeah that's a
good way
liyan it diffuses the flight that's
really really smart you say that till
you tell me you know a lot of times if
they you know what you're doing when you
do that you become present so you let
the girl vent you let her do what she's
got to do but you're there and you're
not trying to [ __ ] solve you're
listening listen Eric Griffin what if
what if I didn't do anything wrong what
is my credits - what if mr. Griffin it's
something else affecting her and I'm
just there for the [ __ ] demolition
derby yep you know I'm saying that's
wouldn't that's why you're her best
friend I know but I don't always want to
be was that yeah you do no I do
wait a moment sometimes I'm like ah [ __ ]
cuz like okay so the other day I think
he's channel got to monetize right yeah
and she had a full-on [ __ ] Marsh
attack meltdown dude she was like I
would - right so the whole channel her
vlog Channel right so why because she
changed her address and so these [ __ ]
are like well were you gonna resubmit
you for monetization and she's like oh
my god and then all our videos would
Monica's right so she was [ __ ] losing
it and I was just like I'm on vacation
I'm not doing this [ __ ] she's taking out
on you or she's just taking out like I'm
to the air I mean dude it was taking on
the room hold on hold on here's the
thing yeah here's the thing the closest
person to you is the person you can be
your most vulnerable self with the most
angry is it one that I know I do I do
I know but leadership as well world no
[ __ ] McDonald's I'm not open 24 hours
all the time you know what he's saying
is he wants to see this is why we have
resentment because we want you're on
vacation yeah so in your mind you're
thinking hey we're on vacation like I
said I'm on [ __ ] vacation don't treat
me I think we spent [ __ ] five g's on
right he's got some exact but for God
for her she's like I need this support
right now and for her support is you
being a punching bag
[Laughter]
that's the support she wants to see what
she like if it was if it was physical
she wants you to like stand there like
this and let her like go like this in
your stomach also doing it in front of
the Bills game I'm like it's one of
those things with those one of though
that's one of those like situations that
we just have to accept that that's part
of our job in the relationship you know
I mean it's a hard thing I often do but
this time I was like I just want my
[ __ ] told me some advice though don't
hold on to the resentment no I didn't we
always solve that a little ah true this
thief just want all the blood that comes
out after like what no but what I'm
saying is like the fact that you're
feeling it right now means that you
still have the resentment and what I was
for the bit no no it was true even still
though no it's really just explorative
because you're talking about your chick
with you but I honestly mostly deal with
environmental things it's not usually
things that I do to her it's usually
things that happen to her and then I'm
there for it
we'll check this out trigger so and you
haven't seen what she does tag or fibro
here do they know men and women like we
use the same words but we don't always
speak the same language never ever and
we don't always look at the same things
either like what you just said this is I
take a picture they don't even read a
definition in the dictionary we gotta
take a picture I say take a picture of
my girl right at dinner or something I
said it me take a picture over and I
look at how you [ __ ] up around no no I
go like this oh man you look so great
she looks at him he goes oh my god you
know my freak and she's like my mom but
the lines of my eyes and other stuff and
I'm looking like I'm even looking at
that [ __ ] your point though my boy is
how we look at things we don't look at
them differently ever look what the guys
think they're buff when they're really
fat though so I get it yeah but that
just tells you how
the guys are no no that's different that
delusion guys are very positive delusion
that's not what I'm saying that's
different what I'm saying is because
they're looking at their eye lines and
they're looking at things that we're not
looking at my girls are big on her part
okay what she puts her hair like this if
the part isn't straight she that's the
[ __ ] she's looking at I'm not looking at
that
Sam what I'm seeing is like I see beauty
I see you know Hart leg through their
eyes I'm looking at everything else they
wouldn't let you look beautiful
but what I'm saying is because she's
seeing something different I have to
recognize that and just be like okay
okay well this is it let's take a
picture again I'll slap are you going to
Europe I wouldn't knock some sense into
her yeah if only you threw a chair in
front of her then she'd understand
exactly that's absolutely really like
you know you know like in the 1930s or
40s will way too heavy bang built up the
last right to resent me that's all I'm
saying
life is too short that's it that's all
it is it's like guys and girls yeah both
I think like people hold onto all these
emotions and they're not able to move
for and be present and progress and
whatever thing they're doing you've got
to release it like calm yeah it's just
hard to let go of it's hard to let go of
like into whatever the fight is about it
don't matter what it is yes I'd say that
for every toilet seat or whatever the
[ __ ] it is you had that moment of being
like what up [ __ ] did I marry this chick
you know the moment what he doesn't
think that he does no never
baby I don't I see perfect you see what
he just did he's in or near where I
learned this last ten minutes
I already learned launch it smart lime
mm-hmm no that's the best way it's not
lies just like he just let it go is no
you know what it is not about lives
about it's not that serious yeah
being in a different world serious but
Erica from what if your wife is
screaming Olivia says my name you'll
wipe this screaming or head up next to
you and it's like hurting your eardrum
check this out you're with her because
you can't be with a regular chick that's
so true sir mess you would be you would
be bored out of your mind
dude I guess so but would be bored out
of your mind you need somebody that's a
regular chick oh my god I could call
that this is trouble my exes
oh wait wait wait you know wait you know
what something that I started to realize
about my chick I was like I was one day
she was like saying something to me like
like but she was poking at me you know
and I stopped it up because I wasn't
getting angry and I looked at her
ballpark's yeah yeah verbal pokes you
know like you know she's trying to rile
me up you know and I looked at I said I
was like oh you you trying to get under
my skin right now oh I thought is that
you talking you slapped no no I was like
I was like you trying to get under my
skin you doing this [ __ ] on purpose you
know and I looked at it I was like she
really was trunk they do that what'd she
say when you said that she started to
laugh cuz she was like oh she caught her
sausage yeah I am I doing this
yeah it was like just like they just
like to do it she's a biker girls a brat
yeah they're brats - mine's a brat yeah
they're just brat so you know what you
do what you got to say that take them
daycare no daycare is that like Neiman
Marcus listen I just did me tell you
something that just happened I damn
I was gonna go I was gonna take her on a
trip you know cuz I have United I'm on
iFly United all the time and I'm almost
1k again so I have to go on one trip to
get my one cave what does that mean a
year it's like the highest status
you know like always get first class
yeah it for the for the for the year
around isn't [ __ ] I was gonna take her
on a trip for two days and then I got
this gig that paid me a [ __ ] ton of
money so I couldn't that's like hey baby
and she was like whoop she was you know
and I was like alright go to a date let
me take you to try take took her did you
tell her that mount like yes I was like
they don't care
uses a chair she doesn't care about
money no no they don't listen they don't
give a [ __ ] if I told her she okay yeah
that if it was something this she was
worked herself up to go on this romantic
trip and in her mind or it were already
there not just that you know I'm ready
to go it's like but maybe I'm about to
make such a such amount of money just it
didn't reminds me okay but it's still a
letdown
you just don't be disappointed why
Center I got Day Spa I was like $500
yeah it would be so great if you're
talking about hotel circus circus' at
Las Vegas actually I have a suggestion
for both of you guys please you when you
get home with your wife tonight you guys
go and take the love language test
oh we do that quite a bit we've done
that right yeah but what is it do you
know of language I can't remember [ __ ]
you don't know your wife's love I forgot
you have to know what the number one is
yeah you know what the problem is have
you ever done it back to back to back to
back
nothing I guess you never done about
cuz so so because chicks are so because
chicks are so emotional don't let them
take it you read the questions and you
click it if you take it five times back
to back the love languages are different
every single time which depends on a
moment yeah exactly
you know what the context of it's great
how you answer those questions yeah the
questions themselves to me are more
telling than the results because the
questions will be like you know like one
of the one of those like when you come
home do you want some time to yourself
or or you want immediately to see you
you know those kind of things really it
tells you like how do you think about
things but the reason what's our blame
oh yes the context because for me I'm
like I mean Steve knows I'm the most
technical like black and white personal
world so this works really bad for my
know too because I'll be like I'll be
like okay cool future space I win an
Oscar I'm gonna go she needs her space
keep it to myself and I'll go and then
later you'll you [ __ ] tall job before
me hahaha language says you need to keep
it to yourself work with common sense
hook me up I'm so black and white in my
mind if you can't won an Oscar for
somebody you just said to me you have to
work on right now is life is in black
and white I know my god life is nuanced
yeah that's the first time he's heard
I'm learning know what's so weird about
him though is that while you say that he
is a creative person like we've written
home some movies and stuff together
highly creative so like how the [ __ ]
does that work right he's so technical
and yet he can do stories and [ __ ] yeah
because it's easy to coach but it's hard
to play yeah you know I know what that
means
cochin heart of play Oh Cassie okay yeah
you just said it again welcome to my
understand oh I got it
did you put you off the shelf put it
back on I don't know I just think you
know what it's fine
relationships are there they're
challenging let's not say hard challenge
chance but but you have to know like
what you're at what you want the end
result to be and the reason why I long
term relationship commitments or getting
married as important is because you
can't be thinking I have a way out
that's what's wrong with dating per se
so when these fights you always go I
have a back door out of here
but when you're married or you're in a
committed relationship your thought is I
love this person we're gonna get past
we're gonna fight to the end we're gonna
fight to service that's rule of language
yeah all right that's crazy but it's
always whatever the love language is and
also be a punching bag for me yes you
know what knowing the rank of it is
important because you know what's funny
my number one is acts of service you
know but still but my girls like
physical touch and then like receiving
gifts now check it out this gifts thing
when you hear that you might think oh
man that's like gold digger ish you
don't I mean it's not at all no but some
people it sounds like yes and some
people think that but that's not what it
is I'm telling you right now sometimes
during the day if I'd be like hey here's
a $10 gift sir to ever get to Starbucks
go get you you know I know you feeling
whatever or here's this it's so
thoughtful it's a it's a it's a little
bit stop but the response is so like
overwhelmingly I feel like oh then what
just do that
even if there's a problem your love
language might not be the other person's
love language right so you don't you
don't you don't take value in like in
the same way but as long as you
recognize that this person has they take
that value high then just give them that
I see but it but the problem is that if
she got not like same event americano
and a spinach feta wrap
dad that gift card she's gonna have to
whip up with a powder never card so you
got a fancy [ __ ] that's what you're a
little bit no 25 I gotta go 30 I got the
same I got the same issue my girl bought
some $800 shoes god oh my god and then
here's a thing I could have a shoes and
she's doing like this
we don't even marry so this is her money
so she ain't gonna dog she bought for
herself she bought a horse oh yeah I
know that still but she's trying to
explain it to me like you don't
understand you know my fee Bubba blah
Jimmy Choos like I was like people are
wearing to 1,200 shoes all the time and
they're fine and I said to her hey stop
with all this just say I'm a fancy [ __ ]
and Islanders yeah own it just own it
yeah you know just say that we don't got
to go through all this nonsense exactly
you don't I mean I feel what I'm saying
is don't be resentful that they don't
want to use logic your logic is skewed
they don't wanna they don't want to oh
[ __ ] like that man you know what they
don't want to own being crazy and all
the time yeah why is that we're not
crazy what do you guys are the craziest
[ __ ] linear thinking you got so
for you linear these guys when these
good guys put holes in this wall
you don't understand what that actually
means the violence of that act or
whatever language V thing you say but
you're not think so anything that it's
just a release for them that's all we're
trying to say need arose okay thank you
I'm very mad at you
[Laughter]
yeah no I just anyways I just feel like
you know don't hold on to things that's
my biggest advice don't hold on yeah
well could you keep going to that whole
resentment thing right so don't ever
think what it is - it's in order to not
hold on to resentment whoever is like so
in a couple right
one person does some shoe and you're
saying that to this person don't hold
the resentment right but then this
person also has to recognize what they
have done so then this person can let go
of it no you gotta just the partnership
here where it's like it's uh if you're
in it together then yeah you have to own
what you did and then you have to be
able to let it go yeah but but the thing
is like if our thought processes are
processed differently yes I think it is
a responsibility sometimes of the guy to
just be like let this thing be like out
of control emotional sometimes it's like
you know we just have to be like okay I
see what's happening right now and let
me just take a step back and just be
okay with it that's the hard part
it does soften the blow when someone
else is there supporting you but I think
forgiveness and letting go of resentment
is interpersonal work and it doesn't
include anyone else and the new problem
it goes out to you problem yes and
whether it's just in a relationship or
friendship where any a family or
whatever it's very important to do that
because you're only hurting yourself
right and it's not analyze it you know
the thing is you don't realize it until
later like in any situation to me you
have to look and see what you are
responsibility absolutely
it always starts with just and if you
can because we can only control yourself
but that's guys we guys are thought
every guys had this thought she's acting
[ __ ] crazy she's not making sense
why is she [ __ ] mad about something
that she shouldn't be mad about and
we're like you would like just let it go
why are we fighting about this but in
that what we're doing this yeah that's
what the problem is in that moment yeah
cuz I'd you know what I ain't closing on
this this is what happens we start a
fight about something like a real thing
and then we start fighting about how
we're fighting that's how I yeah that's
how every fight goes man so stupid
it starts with like you know you didn't
plug the Tesla in how could mean to blow
the Teslin you know it could be of
something like that you know bet you now
we can't go what we need to go and then
now you're lucky maybe you were wrong
you should have plugged it in right but
that he's going you know like Danny like
hey don't yell at me I'm not yelling at
you it now we fight me show you yelling
you know means you're fighting about
somebody were fighting about the fight
just trying to watch the bills game rise
[Music]
[Music]